denise this year most people and
organizations skipped the usual
inauguration watch parties due to the
pandemic
people from one local non-profit make it
work nevada
they wanted to watch it together joe
mohler stopped by their office in
downtown las vegas and has their
reaction
[Music]
it was a very historic day while most
watched the inauguration from home or
virtually a small group of people
working to make change wanted to make
sure they watched history in the making
together
we felt it was important to like turn a
new page together
and feel the optimism make it work
nevada is a non-profit political
advocacy group for black women and
families
members here say what president joe
biden is bringing to the nation
brings them hope there's a weight that
has been lifted even though we still
have so much work to do
no uh elected official is perfect and
you know we're always feeling like we
have to push for policies that
folks in the margins need but now we
actually have a chance president biden
is making history with the first female
vice president
and one of the most diverse
administrations he can see
that it doesn't matter
necessarily what someone looks like or
or in their background
that they can lead and that they can be
more that we can dream for bigger things
with the election and now inauguration
over people hope the president will hit
the ground running
we have a lot of work left to do as a
country it's good to hear
some decency i'm hoping that we figure
out a way to
curb this coronavirus that we get back
to some sense of normalcy
not to me yesterday's challenges
reporting in las vegas joe moeller 8
news now